millions of people are expected to march
across the globe demanding that world
leaders take action on climate change
here's the scene in Berlin this morning
protests will take place in more than a
hundred and fifty countries on all seven
continents they come ahead of a United
Nations climate conference next week mts
tyub is with demonstrators in London
India's what's the scene there good
morning that's right a major protest
here in London and indeed right across
the planet led largely by school-aged
children who say now is the time to
strike back against climate change over
in Australia we have already seen
hundreds of thousands take to the
streets there are also major
mobilizations planned for across europe
asia and later today in cities across
the u.s. they're also going to join in
with the huge number of people expected
to turn out in New York it's all part of
the fridays for future movement started
by sixteen-year-old swedish schoolgirl
greta tunberg just this week Chung Berg
went before Congress to deliver a pretty
blunt message saying sorry guys you're
just not working hard enough on the
issue of climate change now here in
London we've been speaking to protests
who say climate change is the defining
issue of their time and that more isn't
done we're gonna see a lot more protests
like this Tony
MT has tie up on the ground for us in
London MTS thank you very much